in the world of baseball there's one
team that's gone truly bananas we're
talking about the savannah bananas what
a name in georgia a team attracting
millions of fans with their tick tock
videos showing batters on stilts and
players in kilts including a former
world series champion pitcher the team
circus-like antics regularly draw sell
out crowds now they're planning to take
their viral show on the road chris van
cleave gives us the play-by-play
[Applause]
millions of social media views
sold out stadiums
and a waiting list 80 000 fans long
the savannah bananas are a home run that
came very close to striking out we just
didn't know if people were going to
believe in our vision
jesse and emily cole created this
baseball banana land when we first
showed up the former team had cut the
phone lines they cut the internet lines
they took everything out of the ballpark
we only sold a handful of tickets in our
first three months the couple sold their
home to make payroll just trying to make
it to opening day at the point where
you're selling your home living on an
air mattress
were you like is this worth it
i never hesitated with our pursuit of
building the dream we really
were so blindly optimistic
that i don't think we ever slowed down
enough to say maybe this won't work
savannah had a long history of not so
successful baseball teams so locals were
skeptical then the team's name went
viral and their first game sold out so
is nearly every game since
jesse in his banana yellow tuxedo is the
ring master of this part circus part
vaudeville part pretty good baseball
with a few rule changes and a directive
to have fun how did you change the game
it was
the idea of looking at every single slow
boring friction point of a baseball game
and doing the exact opposite
like a groovin tick-tock dance before
pitcher kyle lug hurls a strike viewed
more than 43 million times
we look for ways to stand out
teammate and his catcher bill leroy
this guy's out there twisting around
doing the jerk or twerking or whatever
else and then booming through the strike
right the middle blows it by a guy what
do you say to the baseball purists who
are like this isn't baseball it's like
whether you're a purist of the game or
if you like really enjoy what we do
we're all trying to grow the game for
the next generation looking around the
stands on a steamy tuesday night in
savannah with thousands clad and what
else banana costumes
it's working when you think of baseball
what do you normally think
i think of uh
you know like rules that you don't
really understand
no music no fun
ladies and gentlemen and how would you
describe this
party
party
entertainment the best show ever
viral moments be it the dancing umpire a
flaming bat
and both runners off on the pitch a
player on stilts or in a kilt happen all
night long
[Applause]
and don't forget the banana nana's
senior dance team what is your favorite
part about being a banana nana
the dancing just hearing the crowd roar
when we do specific moves the positivity
of everything that happens here in
banana land we swing in banana ball
you swing for the fences
always with everything
[Applause]
a big bet showing this bunch of bananas
has a lot of appeal
for cbs mornings i'm chris van glee
savannah
last month owner jessie cole announced
the savannah bananas intend to take
their show on the road starting in 2023
they will be playing banana ball all
over the country bananas balls rules
include a two hour time limit no walks
no bunting and foul balls cut by fans
can counting is outs how fun is that
it's all designed to make it more
efficient i just if i'm the visiting
team
how do you tolerate them you ain't
putting up with that well i don't know
or are you worn in advance like it's
going to get sillier i would think that
kind of storytelling is it reminds me of
why i love this show in the news
business because we get to tell stories
in anywhere america that are fun you
should take your kids to something like
that yeah they love that it is it's
chris appealing the players actually do
not get paid but the team has more
social media followers than any major
league baseball team make money off that
yeah